>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Ladies and Gentleman, please
welcome the 14th Librarian
of Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: Thank you!
>> Carla Hayden: Good evening!
And welcome to the 2017 National
Book Festival Gala Celebration,
the opening of the festival.
It is my great honor to be part
of the institution that organizes,
and presents this wonderful
public event.
Every year, for 17 years,
the Library of Congress,
has brought the nations greatest
Authors, Poets, and Illustrators,
to the Nation's Capitol, and put
them together with book lovers
who come from as far away as
North Carolina, and Michigan,
to hear them talk about their work.
Everyone here tonight is part
of that extraordinary effort,
and I thank you for
joining us this year.
I want to say a few words about
a number of people who can't be
with us here, because of the
devastating floods in Texas.
Children's author, Tim Tingle, who's
house was in the hurricanes path.
And our interviewers, Keven
Sullivan, and Mary Jordan,
who are in the very thick
of things, getting the news
out for the Washington Post.
Our thoughts are with them, and
with all who have been affected.
Now, you would not be here
if you did not love books.
And we wouldn't be here
if the United States
Congress did not love books.
The members of Congress
are the benefactors,
and overseers of this Library,
the largest cultural institution
in the world, and we thank those
members who are with us today.
[ Applause ]
We have a number of
diplomats in the audience,
who are also book lovers too.
Welcome, to the Ambassadors
of Peru, India, Ladia, Lafia,
and also the Cultural
Counselor of Mexico.
[ Applause ]
And thank you Mexican Cultural
Institute, the Embassy of Columbia,
the Embassy of Arland,
and the Embassy of Sweden,
for helping us bring superb talent
from your countries, to our shores.
Our audience tonight, also
includes the many sponsors
who have contributed to
making this event possible.
Mr. David Rubenstein,
the festival's Co-Chair.
[ Applause ]
Charter sponsors, the Institute of
Museum and Library Services, IMLS,
The Washington Post,
and Wells Fargo.
You may clap.
[ Applause ]
And also, patrons and contributors,
the James Madison Counsel
of the Library of Congress, the
National Endowment for the Arts,
the National Endowment
of the Humanities,
Scholastic Inc., and many others.
Because of their generosity,
the festival remains completely
free, and thank you for that.
[ Applause ]
And there's more.
There are more than a thousand
volunteers who give of their time.
Library of Congress Staff, the
general public, the Junior League
of Washington, and our Introducers
from the Washington Post,
National Public Radio, and
numerous other media organizations.
And speaking of Library staff,
a team of more than a dozen,
have worked on planning
tomorrows event,
which will offer the most
impressive line up of Authors
in the 17 year history
of the festival.
And so I'd like to especially
acknowledge our Festival organizers,
Director Jared McNeil [assumed
spelling], Literary Director,
Maria Arana [assumed spelling].
[ Applause ]
And of course, a big thank you
to Sue Seagle [assumed spelling],
of our Development Office.
[ Applause ]
Now, the lively image you see
here, is from our Festival poster,
and it was designed
by the delightfully
talented artist, RosChes.
[applause] And she wanted to convey
the idea, one that we all recognize,
and know, that books are fun!
And they're shared experiences,
personal and communal.
Books ask questions,
and they aspire answers.
They are essential to the human
experience, and they open us
to possibilities we might
otherwise never see.
Our theme tonight is the
American Story, and I can't think
of a better subject to relay
the energy and diversity,
that all of the story
tellers here tonight,
and at the festival, will bring.
In fact, I must take a moment
to recognize some of our newest,
and youngest contributors
to the American Story.
We have with us tonight, the
newly pinned, and recognized,
2017 National Student Poets.
Would you please stand up?
These five young people--
[ Applause ]
These five young people will be
spending the next year bringing
words and the magic of
words, to young people all
over throughout the country.
They represent the five
regions of the country.
And they are, I think,
are the embodiment
of what this festival is about.
One of the great traditions of
the festival has always been
to bestow the Library
Of Congress prize
for American Fiction,
on festival day.
This years winner, Denis Johnson,
to whom I offered the prize in March
of this year, died tragically
a few months later, in May.
We are honoring this great figure
in Contemporary American
Fiction tomorrow
with a posthumous conferral
of the prize.
It will be presented at the
very top of our Fiction Stage,
and relayed to his Widow, Cindy
Johnson [assumed spelling],
along with the citations about
Denis we have gathered from more
than a dozen literary
figures from around the world.
And since we always feature our
winner at this Gala evening,
we offer you now a very
brief video on the life,
and work of Denis Johnson.
>> English words are like
prisons, empty, nothing inside,
and still they make rainbows.
So says a character in "Already
Dead", a Novel by the late,
great American writer,
Denis Johnson.
Johnson's stories, as legions of
his fans know, are also prisons.
They are hard, merciless, flinty,
and yet they too, make rainbows.
He's been called a writer's writer's
writer, and for all the indigma
of that string of words,
they hold a simple truth.
Those who bring language to life,
recognize Johnson's gifts instantly.
Louise Erdrich calls his work
profound, and transcendent.
Jonathan Franzen finds his sentences
miracles of transparency and tone.
Phillip Roth, calls him daring,
terrifying, and an emissary
for tortured, broken souls.
Marilyn Robinson marvels that
a writer's personal passions,
and energies, can be so
inextricably wedded to his words.
All agree, Denis Johnson has
managed to give us minimalist,
yet distinctly ecstatic, and
hallucinatory rainbow probes.
He is an American original.
He was born in 1949, in Munich,
Germany, and raised in Tokyo,
and Manila, the child
of American diplomats.
As a teenager, moving
back to Washington D.C.,
during the tumultuous 60's,
he came to know the country,
and the restless characters he would
capture so vividly in his fiction.
He graduated in English
Literature, from University of Iowa,
and earned a MFA, from
the Iowa Writers Workshop,
where he returned as a teacher.
He has also taught
at Texas University,
and the University
of Texas, at Austin.
In the course of his favorite
career, he published novels,
short stories, journalism,
and poetry.
Among with his best works are
those about the Flotsam and Jetsam
of American Life, The
Laughing Monsters, Nobody Move,
Tree of Smoke, Already Dead, Jesus'
Son, Resuscitation of a Hanged Man,
The Stars at Noon,
Fiskadora, Angels.
He's received numerous
awards for these,
including a national book award,
a Lannan Fellowship in fiction,
a writing writers award,
and in 2008,
he was named a finalist
for the Pulitzer Prize.
Throughout, he has chronicled an
America that has gone unobserved,
unrecorded, here are our drug
addicts, our war veterans,
our disaffected, our
used up and left behind,
and yet the most affecting,
and rewarding aspect
of Denis Johnson's fiction
is that in work, after work,
he has proved that beauty often
lurks in unexpected places,
that strength can be
found in failure,
that the human spirit is a
fragile, but resilient vessel.
His is a very American Story.
He once described his works as
pressure cookers of language,
his characters as those who
inhabit life's perilous edge.
As time wore on, he found that
he himself was all too vulnerable
to these human frailties.
When the Librarian of
Congress, Carla Hayden,
offered Denis Johnson the Library of
Congress Prize for American Fiction,
in March of 2017, he
wrote in an email message,
"My head is spinning
from such great news".
Two months later, tragically,
he was dead.
The Library is very proud
to honor, posthumously,
this extraordinary human being,
and writer, who's contributions
to the American can and have
been been lasting and invaluable.
As the Librarian wrote, when the
prize was announced in June of 2017,
Denis Johnson was a writer for our
times, in prose that fused grace
with wit, he spun tale after
tale about our walking wounded,
the demons that haunt,
the salvation we seek.
We emerge from his imagined
world, with profound empathy,
a different perspective,
a little changed.
We're very proud to count Denis
Johnson among the distinguished
winners of the Library of Congress
Prize for American Fiction.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: Thank you!
The National Book Festival is
not only a celebration of books
and reading, but also
of literacy itself.
Life, in these demanding times,
can be very difficult for those
who have never learned to
read, and unfortunately,
there are too many
people in that number,
in this country, and
around the world.
The latest estimate, is that 65
percent of adults in the world,
are functionally illiterate.
At the Library, it is an
important part of our mission
to comet illiteracy, and
promote a culture of reading,
and one of the most generous
supporters of American Culture,
History, and the Arts in this
country is Mr. David Rubenstein,
Co-Chair of the National Book
Festival, and is primary donor.
His patriotic philanthropy can
be seen all across Washington,
at the Kennedy Center, the National
Zoo, the Washington Monument,
and at the new National Museum
of African American
History and Culture.
But his work can also be seen all
across the country, and the world.
He is a tireless promoter of
literacy, and he believes in books,
libraries, and the opportunity, and
success that are [inaudible] linked,
and I trust they are for
all of us here tonight.
His dedication to increasing
literacy across the world,
let to his creation and
support of the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards.
And I now invite you to watch
another video we have prepared,
about the Literacy awards, and
David's involvement in them.
[ Music ]
>> People who can read, and
do, are healthier, happier,
and live longer than
people who can't.
They are more likely to get
preventative health care,
and are less likely to
go to an emergency room.
Women and girls who are
educated, have fewer children,
and those they do have, are
twice as likely to survive.
Everyone benefits from literacy.
For every one percent increase
in a country's literacy rate,
there is a permanent
1.5 percent increase
in it's gross domestic product.
But illiteracy is widespread,
worldwide 758 million adults,
most of them women, cannot read
or write a simple sentence.
Illiteracy contributes
to poverty, and crime.
43 percent of adults with the lowest
literacy levels, live in poverty.
70 percent of adult welfare
recipients have trouble reading.
75 percent of state prison inmates
did not complete high school.
Illiteracy is expensive,
low literacy cost the U.S.
225 billion dollars each year
in lost work force productivity,
crime, and unemployment.
And illiteracy cost the global
economy 1.19 trillion each year.
Launched with the creative
vision, and generosity
of David M. Rubenstein, the Library
of Congress Literacy
Awards recognize,
and promote the achievements of
organizations, who's innovative,
research based practices, are
improving literacy, worldwide.
Since 2013, these awards
have provided more
than one million dollars to 77
institutions, in 24 countries.
This year, a committee of Literacy
Experts, evaluated 59 nominations,
and presented their findings
to the Librarian of Congress
who selected winners
in three categories.
The 50 thousand dollar international
prize, recognizes significant,
and measurable contributions
to increasing literacy levels,
by an organization based
outside the United States.
The 50 thousand dollar American
prize recognizes significant,
and measurable contributions
to increasing literacy
levels, on a national level.
The 150 thousand dollar
David M. Rubenstein prize,
recognizes a domestic, or
international organization
that is demonstrated
exceptional, and sustained depth,
in it's commitment to the
advancement of literacy.
Please join Librarian of
Congress, Carla Hayden,
and Literacy Awards
founder, David M. Rubenstein,
in recognizing the
achievements, and innovations
of the three organizations selected
as winners of the 2017 Library
of Congress Literacy Awards.
[ Applause ]
>> Ladies and Gentleman, please
welcome David M. Rubenstein,
Co-Chairman of the National Book
Festival, and the originator,
and sponsor of the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards.
>> David Rubenstein: Carla, thank
you very much for your kind words,
and thank you for your dedication
to the National Book Festival,
and the cause of literacy.
We are thrilled that you are
the Librarian of Congress,
I am particular thrilled that
you came here from Baltimore,
my home town, where you headed the
library, for some 20 years there.
It is hard to believe,
you saw that film,
that it's not just a global
problem, it's an American problem.
45 million Americans are
functionally illiterate, 45 million.
We have about 330 million Americans,
45 million are functionally
illiterate,
which means that they can't
read beyond a fifth grade level.
If you can't read beyond a
fifth grade level your chance
of having economic success in
life is reduced dramatically.
People who don't have the
ability to read earn, on average,
40 percent less than
people who can read,
and that is a real tragic situation.
In our Country, we talk
about the income gap,
and the growing income gap, but
it's really a growing literacy gap,
and the income gap it's directly
related to the literacy gap.
Unless we can do something
about closing literacy gap,
we have no chance of
closing the income gap.
We also have no chance of dealing
with some of the side effects
of literacy that were mentioned.
For example, if you are
illiterate, functionally illiterate,
your chance of being a juvenile
delinquent is dramatically
increased, in fact 85 percent
of all juvenile delinquents
are functionally illiterate,
and as our statistics showed,
roughly two thirds of people who are
in our prison system, are
functionally illiterate.
It's a sad situation,
and we have not made
as much progress as we should.
Think about this in your
case, suppose in your case,
every body here, I presume, is
literate, I hope everybody is.
[laughter] But suppose you couldn't
read, think about your life,
how would your life be
different if you couldn't read?
You'd gone through you entire
life, and you couldn't read.
Not only would you, probably
be more likely to be part
of our criminal justice system,
not only would you likely have a
much lower income for your family,
but the pleasure that you get
from reading would be gone.
To me, one of the great
pleasures of my life is reading,
and I just can't imagine my life
without the ability to read.
But think about your own
lives, how would your life be
so different if you couldn't read?
That's the problem we have
with some 45 million Americans,
and it's growing.
And let me just mention one other
problem, not just illiteracy,
as great as that problem is,
but the problem of a-literacy.
Their are people who can
read, but don't read.
It's hard to believe.
But 31 percent of American males,
last year, who are literate,
did not read a single book.
In fact, 26 percent of all Americans
who can read, didn't read a book
at all last year, and 40 percent
of all high school graduates
who can read, did not read
a book at all last year.
Now as we all know,
reading is very important,
but reading books is
a special pleasure.
The National Book Festival
emphasizes, not just literacy,
but the value of books, and the
importance of reading books.
So, I hope all of you, when
you leave here tonight,
and when you finish the
Book Festival tomorrow,
for those who are going, think about
how privileged you are to be able
to read, and how sad your life
would be if you couldn't read.
And so all of us should be
thrilled wit our parents,
our teachers who taught us us how
to read, and we should really be sad
that there are so many
people in this country
who can't get the pleasure out
of reading that all of us have.
So, to the extent that you can think
about, one thing you might be able
to do after you leave the
festival, it is something
that I hope you might be able
to do, to contribute to somebody
with your time, your
energy ideas, your money,
to help support the
effort to eradicate,
and dramatically reduce
illiteracy, and hopefully reduce
and erratically, and
dramatically produce a-literacy.
It's a tragic situation that we
have to all deal with, and again,
the income gap in this
country is not going away
until the literacy gap goes away.
Thank you!
[ Applause ]
>> Ladies and Gentleman, the winner
of the 2017 International Prize
of the Library of Congress
Literacy Awards, is Prothom Books,
creator of Story Reader, an
online digital repository,
that offers stories in
mother tongue languages,
free of charge, to
children in India.
Accepting the award for
Prothom books is Chairperson,
Miss Suzanne Sink [assumed
spelling].
[ Applause ]
Ladies and Gentleman, the winner
of the 2017 American Prize
of the Library of Congress Literacy
Awards, is the National Center
for Families Learning, which
works with community partners
to develop model programs,
and innovative laboratories
that advance family literacy.
Accepting the award
for the National Center
for Families Learning is
President and Founder,
Miss Sharon Darling
[assumed spelling].
[ Applause ]
Ladies and Gentleman, the winner of
the 2017 David M. Rubenstein Prize
of the Library of Congress
Literacy Awards,
is the Children's Literary
Initiative,
which delivers content
focused coaching to educators,
who work in under resourced schools,
with lagging literacy achievement,
equipping them with high impact
strategies, and techniques
for literacy instruction, and
providing their classrooms
with high quality children's
literature.
Accepting the award
for the Children's Literary
Initiative is Chief Executive
Officer, Dr. Joel Zaro
[assumed spelling].
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: And David, and
thank you to all the winners,
but we have something for you.
>> David Rubenstein: Uh-oh!
[laughter]
>> Carla Hayden: It's okay.
We'd like to present you with
a token of our appreciation
for all you have done to
make the Literacy Awards,
and the National Book
Festival a success.
So, here is a specially
framed facsimile
of the book lovers map
of the United States.
And you'll see that it has portraits
of great American writers
including Ralph Waldo Emerson,
Nathaniel Hawthorne, and Edgar
Allan Poe, Baltimore, [laughter],
Walt Wickman, and Mark Twain,
and all the places they're from.
But thank you David!
>> David Rubenstein:
Thank you very much!
>> Carla Hayden: Really, thank you!
[ Applause ]
And now, ladies and
gentleman, our terrific lineup
of Authors will give us their views
on what the American
Story means to them.
>> Ladies and gentleman, please
welcome Margot Lee Shetterly.
[ Applause ]
>> Margot Lee Shetterly: Wow!
It is such an honor for me to be
here in a room full of writers.
So many of my literary
hero's here tonight.
America may be the only country
in the world founded
by a bunch of writers.
Jefferson, Hamilton,
Madison, Franklin, their pro's
and their lucid ideas, about the
nature of humanity, and freedom,
is some of the most admired,
and influential writing
in the history of the world.
America's essentially a work of
imagination, so it's no surprise
that we, as citizens,
devote so much our lives
to pursuing an American dream,
and to telling an American Story.
Growing up in Virginia, in
the 1970's 80's however,
I could never seem to find
my story in American history.
I remember elementary school,
and junior high school,
and dreading those few days when
the Social Studies Curriculum turned
it's eyes to Black History.
There was slavery, Martin Luther
King, and that was about it.
Black History in the classroom
was always a discussion
of racial violence, and
disenfranchisement, and shame.
The idea that simply by virtue
of the color of their skin,
my fore-bearers were considered
legally, socially, and economically,
less than full citizens of this
country, and less than fully human.
The textbooks offered cursory
information about the state
of blacks, in America, but virtually
nothing about Black Americans,
as individuals, who, as I
knew firsthand were as engaged
in the pursuit of life,
liberty, and happiness,
as any other citizen in of country.
Where were the stories
of the protagonists?
I grew up in a world
where robust families,
and members of a dynamic community
dreamed of a better future,
and they found ways, great and
small, to fight against injustice.
They did all they could to
help people do their best work,
whether that work was
cleaning other people's houses,
as my grandmother did, or
calculating orbital trajectories,
as did the women that I write
about, in Hidden Figures.
Where in those History books were,
for example, the business people
who pooled their resources
to provide mortgages
to black home owners?
Or the teachers, like my mother,
or the scientists, like my father.
Well there was the Chemist,
George Washington Carver,
and he was the black scientist that
everybody heard about during class.
And they had that poor guy working
overtime during Black History month.
[laughter].
In general however, I could
not square the textbooks narrow
and degraded presentation
of the past with my present,
and I certainly had problems
attaching that past to my future.
I was an ambitious handful
of a whippersnapper,
ready to take on the world,
and as far as I was concerned,
history was simply ballaced, it was
something meant to be off loaded
if I was going to be able to rise,
and pursue my version
of the American dream.
So it's no surprise that when
I graduated from the University
of Virginia, I chose a career that
seemed to meet the perfect opposite
of history, Investment Banking.
[laughter] but as hard as I tried, I
simply could not outrun the history.
After decades of living and working
outside of Virginia, and in fact,
outside of the United
States, I recently moved
to Charlottesville, Virginia.
So today, not only am I working
as a writer, and a historian,
I am living history, in a way that
is terrifying and fascinating,
and that I never thought
would occur in my lifetime.
The recent White Supremacists
March happened on the grounds
of the school where I spent
four years of my life.
The counter protests and
the attack took place
in Downtown Charolettesville,
the confederate statues
that ignited the firestorm,
are a 20 minute walk
from where I currently live.
Now there's been a lot of
talk around Charolettesville,
and around the country, about how
what happened there three weeks ago,
doesn't represent Charolettesville,
or America,
as we currently believe it to be.
I love my country passionately,
I love my native state,
and I love my adopted city, but
I also know the painful history,
and what happened on August 12th,
that to Charolettesville,
and America.
It's an America that has
battled the betters angels
of our nature from the beginning.
For example, from the 1930's
to the 1950's, my Alma mater,
and other Virginia Universities,
payed qualified black students
to attend Graduate School out of
state, rather than to allow them
to continue their educations
at home, in Virginia.
Virginia closed schools,
rather than complying
with the Supreme Court's Brown
versus Board of Education decision,
and allowing the blacks of
the hidden figures generation,
to learn alongside whites.
And that was nearly a century
after the end of the Civil War.
My father is a retired
NASA Scientist.
His name is Robert Lee,
and his family roots are
in West Marlin County,
Virginia, which also happens
to be the birthplace of the
confederate, General Robert E. Lee.
America is about both the slavery,
and racial terror associated
with the confederate monument, and
it is also about those beautiful,
revolutionary ideals of progress,
and freedom that were written
into existence by our
founding documents.
But it's also about
so very much more.
As James Baldwin said, "American
History is longer, larger,
more various, more
beautiful, and more terrible
than anything anyone
has ever said about it.
I believe that one of
the reasons why the push
to remove these statues
is so strong right now,
is because the statues symbolize,
not just the presence of the racial
that tie that marks our history,
but it also signals an absence,
the absence of tails
of people who live,
not just Black lives,
but American lives.
People who pushed our country to
live up to it's founding ideals,
not in-spite of their
history, but because of it.
That absence has created a powerful
vacuum, one that is urgently trying
to absorb the stories of people
like Dorothy Vaughan, Mary Jackson,
Katherine Johnson,
and Christine Darden,
the woman that I write
about in Hidden Figures.
Hidden figures is a Black story,
and it's a Virginian story,
it's a Woman's story, and
it's a Mathematician story,
but most fundamentally
it's an American Story.
In the time since my classroom
days, I've come to understand
that learning History isn't just
an encounter with oppression
or with pain, it's a
necessary condition
for progress, and for social change.
And now I know that storytelling,
that most human of activities,
storytelling determines both
the meaning of our past,
and also the trajectory
of our future.
No one knew that better
than our founding writers.
They wrote our Country
into existence,
and for those of us who's
history here began with a bill
of sale, not the bill of rights.
It is our job to be the
protagonists of our own stories,
and to write our lives into
the great ethic of America.
Thank you!
[ Applause ]
>> Ladies and Gentleman,
please welcome Scott Turow!
[ Applause ]
>> Scott Turow: Tough act to follow.
I'm going to start off
script for one second,
because I was lucky enough to be at
the first National Book Festival,
I've returned from time to time,
and it is certainly my
favorite event of it's kind.
And that is for two reasons.
One, is because, to me, writers
remain the true rock-stars,
and I love being able to breathe the
same air as so many great writers
as are going to be here this
weekend, and are here tonight.
And secondly, if you think about it,
this is the only official National
Celebration that we have of books,
and authors, and readers, and it's
a great thing that we do that.
So I need to thank the Library
of Congress, Dr. Hayden,
David Rubenstein, who's
head is shouldered
to the wheel for several years now.
Maria Rana, everybody else who
has labored to bring this weekend
into being, because it
really is a peak moment
for the American Literary Community.
Anyway, now, of course,
I will talk about myself.
[laughter] As a kid,
I watched too much TV.
That, at least, was the opinion of
my aunt and uncle from California,
which they expressed tirelessly
to my mother whenever they came
to stay with us in Chicago.
The one eyed monster, as my aunt
called it, was going to gnaw
through my brains,
dull me permanently,
and prevent me from reading.
Much to my dismay, my mother
took their warning seriously,
because both my aunt and uncle
were, yes, psychoanalysts,
which to my mother, made them truth
tellers on the level of oracles.
I do have to add that that did not
prevent my mother, years later,
when my aunt and uncle finally
had a family of their own,
didn't prevent my mom, occasionally
from observing how
much easier it was
to give other people high minded
advice about their children,
rather than follow
it with their own.
[laughter] More important, my aunt
and uncle, much as I adored each
of them, had somewhat
missed the point.
Yes, I weaseled my way in front
of the TV, and spent hours there
in a trans state, but I
read a great deal too.
I was, in fact, one of those kids
recklessly absorbed with fantasies,
novels, TV, movies, and above all
the stories running in my own brain.
I was, I guess, accommodating
reality only in very small doses.
If I were my own psychoanalyst
required to explain this,
I would highlight the stark
fears, and vulnerability I felt
in a house dominated by my father,
a man of harsh and mercurial temper.
But whatever the reason, certain
TV shows felt as essentially
to my well being as food and water.
Like so many others, I
worshiped Superman, Defender,
to quote the prologue
of the show, of "Truth,
Justice, and the American Way".
A little less typically, I also
couldn't wait to see Mighty Mouse
on Saturday mornings,
probably on some level,
I equated him with a
child with superpowers.
Also, by the time I was nine or ten,
I made sure to save an hour or two
of my limited TV time,
thanks to my aunt and uncle,
for Perry Mason, on Saturday night.
Perry always discovered the truth,
and made sure that
power was used fairly,
so that the guilty were
punished, and the innocent freed.
As passionately as I gave myself
to these American Stories,
I began to notice a problem as
I got older, they were not true.
Meaning, they did not offer the
clues about surviving in the world,
which I apparently
expected from them.
It is of course, a given
of every childhood,
that there are no Santa Clauses,
or superheros, but in real life,
I realized, there couldn't
even be a Perry Mason.
In time, I grew savvy enough to
realize that Hamilton Burger,
the Hapless District Attorney
couldn't possibly have kept his job
if every week he lost
to Perry Mason.
This struggle between hope
and reality, child and adult,
led to an internal dialogue that
went on inside me for many years,
which I ultimately
ended up incorporating
in my second novel,
The Burden of Proof.
My hero, the defense lawyer, Sandy
Stern, my own answer, I suppose,
to Perry Mason, is long past
his child rearing years,
when Stern unexpectedly finds
himself babysitting for Sam,
a precocious five year old,
who sits down in Stern's lap
as they study the night sky.
"Sandy? Sam said subtly,
" Does good always win?"
Stern nearly asked what Sam was
referring to, but restrained himself
with the thought that
is was unseemly
to be evasive with a five year old.
"No", Stern said finally,
"not always".
It does on TV, the boy said.
This was offered in
part as refutation.
Well it should win, Stern said, That
is what television is showing you.
Why doesn't it win?
It does not always
lose, it wins often,
but it does not win
every time, why not?
Sometimes the other
side is stronger,
sometimes both sides
are good in part,
sometimes neither, Stern thought.
How much does good
win, Sam asked, a lot?
A lot, said Stern.
He had meant to answer,
as many times as it loses,
but he felt this was inappropriate,
and perhaps not even correct.
There was no place for
brutal honesty with a child.
The questions, implicit
in this conversation have been
the obsessions of my adult years.
Deciding what is good
in the first place,
and defining the circumstances in
which it is entitled to triumph,
how to deal fairly with the bad,
and how to survive as a human,
when those efforts founder.
They were, I realize now,
the themes I was writing
about when I made my first serious
efforts at fiction in college,
and they remain my core
emotional concerns,
and drove me from academic life,
to law school in my late 20's.
Furthermore, like all of
my beloved fellow writers
at this wonderful festival, I have
had the extraordinary good fortune
of finding out that these questions,
and the stories I have written
about them, preoccupy, not only
me, but many other Americans.
No surprise really, [inaudible]
told us, that from the start,
the law has been the
binding fabric of America.
That is because we are
not simply a country,
a group of people drawn
together by the common places
of geography, or even language.
Our fellowship in the
United States is based
on a larger mutual
adherence to central ideas.
The government must be
subordination to law,
and what I've always regarded as
the greatest American ideal of all,
the one that Thomas Jefferson, and
his coworkers borrow from John Lach,
namely, that all persons
are created equal.
Our biggest idea is that
government must treat every citizen
with the same concern, and respect,
and guarantee to each citizen,
an equal voice in the governments of
the nation we have formed together.
So my story, as I understand it,
is part of that much larger story,
the one we tell together everyday,
and the one that we must always
strive to make ever truer.
Thank you!
[ Applause ]
>> Ladies and gentleman,
please welcome Reshma Saujani.
[ Applause ]
>> Reshma Saujani:
Thank you so much!
It's a huge honor to be here today.
So when I think about
American Story,
I think about one word, opportunity.
I am, first and foremost,
the daughter of refugees.
My parents came here in the
1970's, after being expelled
by the dictator, Idi
Amin, in Uganda.
They were lucky for one
reason, and one reason alone,
both of my parents were engineers.
And this country, in the 1970's,
was desperately seeking engineers,
so my parents because two
of a thousand refugees
who got status to come
to this country.
And even though they were engineers,
my father worked as a machinist
in a plant, and my
mother sold cosmetics.
My father would send his resume
out day, after day, after day,
and get rejection, after
rejection, after rejection.
Til one day, a recruiter
told him, you know what,
why don't you change your name?
Why don't you change your name from
Mogoon [assumed spelling], to Mike,
and my father did, and he got a job.
Every night, no matter how tired my
dad was, he would sit me on his lap,
he would read to me
about Dr. Kenning,
Mahaf Magandy [assumed
spelling], and Eleanor Roosevelt.
And I knew then, that why I
grew up, I wanted to give back
to this nation, this nation that
had literally saved my parents life.
So at age 33, I decided to do
that, and I ran for Congress,
in a New York City
Democratic Primary,
against a 18 year incumbent,
because I thought
that that was a great idea.
[laughter] I had like a one
percent chance of winning,
a thousand page policy book.
I remember the only thing
my friends and I knew how
to do was build a website,
and we built one,
and we raised like 50 thousand
dollars from Indian Aunties
that were just so happy the
Indian girl was running.
And it was the best
experience of my life.
And I lost, miserably,
I was broke, humiliated,
I had pissed off everybody in
the democratic establishment,
but when I went to bed that
night, and my victory party
that never ended up happening,
the faces that I kept seeing over,
and over, and over again,
were actually the ones
that I had never met
on the campaign trail.
Because as you see, as the
member of Congress who are
in this room understand,
when you run for office,
you end up going into
a lot of schools.
And I would go into Computer
Science classes, and Robotics Labs,
and I'd see hundreds of boys,
clamoring to be the next Steve Jobs,
or Mark Zuckerberg, and I thought
to myself, where are the girls?
And this question of where are
the girls became my obsession,
because it didn't make sense to me.
At a time where women are
the majority in college,
the majority in the labor force,
where are we in this industry
that is literally shaping
our collective future.
And it also didn't make sense to
me, as a daughter of immigrants,
as someone who has benefited
from opportunity, because I knew
that there are 500 thousand
open jobs in Computer MTEC,
and that we had only graduated 40
thousand Computer Science graduates,
compared to China, which
graduated 350 thousand Engineers.
And I also knew that our
families are changing.
That 45 percent of the breadwinners
in our country, were women,
and that it's woman in towns and
perishes that put food on the table,
and pay for the mortgage.
So why were they disappearing
from this industry?
And I realized, well, it
wasn't always this way.
In the 1980's, almost 40 percent of
Computer Science majors were women,
and today that number
is less than 18 percent.
If you were a cynic you would think
that an industry becomes more
powerful, we push women out.
So the failed politician, the
non coder, oh yeah, I don't code,
decided to do something about it.
And I started an organization
called, Girls Who Code.
To offer free programs for girls,
over the summer and after school,
to teach them to get a
shot at the American dream.
And five years later, we've reached
40 thousand girls, in all 50 states.
And as much as I'm a feminist, with
a capital 'F', I do not believe
in gender parody, for the
sake of gender parody,
I believe that when we teach
girls to code, we give them a shot
to march up into the middle
class, and we make sure
that there is no innovation that
will ever be left on the sidelines.
And I see this everyday,
I see this in Jasmine,
who lives in California, Oakland.
Her mother works at Burger King,
single mom, family of four.
Everyday Jasmine would take
two buses and trains to go
from her house to Facebook
to learn how to code.
And in our program, you can
build whatever you want.
Jasmine decided to build
an app called Wacky Words,
to teach kids SAT words, because
too may kids in her community,
they wanted a shot at the American
story, but they didn't have money
for fancy tutors, or
the SAT classes.
She built an app, not for
herself, but to help others.
I think about Courtney, from Carlton
Ohio, father drives an oil rig.
Carlton has been decimated
by the heroin epidemic.
There's no WiFi in the homes,
no WiFi in the schools,
but still every week, 40 girls meet
in the local library to learn how
to code, to get a shot
at the American dream.
The same look that I see in
Courtney's father's eyes,
is the look I saw in my fathers eye.
He would do anything,
and everything for me
to have a shot at the
American dream.
This is possible.
I feel blessed that we've had
an opportunity to write a book,
because year, after year, after
year, we have to turn girls away,
and I want to make sure that girls
across the country have a shot
to march up into the middle class.
I also believe that in
the moment where we feel
that diversity is under attack.
We just recently learned
about Katherine Johnson,
and the tremendous contribution
that she had made to the History
of Computer Science, and that most
of you don't who Ada Lovelace,
or Grace Hopper, or any
other the other women are,
is it important now, more than ever
before to set the record straight,
to make sure that girls see
themselves in these future jobs,
which is why I'm so proud in this
book, that not only do we talk
about Katherine, and Ada, and Grace,
we talk about Lela, and Sofia.
Lela, who wears a hijab, Sofia, who
is Latina, that has an Abuela, Lucy,
who has braids, and loves games.
Every American girl can see
themselves in the stories
in our book, and I truly
believe that through this,
we can change the world, one
book, and one girl at a time.
Thank you!
[ Applause ]
>> Ladies and gentleman,
please welcome Diana Gabaldon.
[ Applause ]
>> Diana Gabaldon: Thank you
very much for being here tonight,
and thanks for having me.
Be relaxed they said,
be casual they said.
[laughter] Do it in
seven minutes they said.
[laughter] Okay!
Guten Abend, which some of you may
know, means good evening, in German,
and the reason I say
that, is because most
of you have no idea how close
we came to having everyone
in this room know what that meant.
Which is to say, at the time
of the American Revolution,
once it had succeeded, and we had
become a nation, Benjamin Franklin,
who was one of the sages of
the revolution at that point,
suggested that since so many of the
citizens at that point were German,
German should be the official
language of the new United States.
That motion went Congress, it was
voted on, it lost, by one vote,
and here we all are, and from
a variety of different places.
My story sort of became the American
Story, other than the obvious,
about who my parents
grandparents, etc. etc., were.
That's much to long of
a story to tell you.
The short form is that when I once
went to Germany to do a book tour,
I was having lunch with the Germans,
and they said, well how did you come
to write these books, and I told
them, and they were shocked,
SHOCKED, you know, to hear that I
had thrown away a perfectly good PhD
in Science, I have a PhD in
Quantitative Behavioral Ecology,
which is just animal
behavior with a lot
of statistics, don't worry about it.
[laughter] My dissertation
was entitled [inaudible],
or as my husband says,
why birds build nests
where they do, and
who cares anyways.
[laughter] Well, the Germans were
still more shocked even more,
when they found out that not only
did I throw away a PhD and 12 years
of career as a successful Scientist,
but that I had not then go back
to school and learn
how to write a novel.
And as they said to me, they
said, no one in Germany would dare
to right a novel before first
getting PhD in Literature,
and I said, that's
probably why two thirds
of your catalog are
American Authors.
Actually I didn't say that
because I have better manners
than that, but it's true.
The thing is, is I was talking
to Scott Turow before dinner,
and we were agreeing that the only
way to learn to write, is to write,
and that's what I thought when
I started writing a novel.
So the question was, what
was I going to write?
And after I thought about it for a
while, I thought, the easiest thing
to write seems to be
Historical Fiction.
Because I was a Research Professor,
I knew my way around a library,
I said it seems easier to look
things up than to make them up,
and if I turn up to have no
imagination, I can steal things
from the historical record.
So, when I began, I said,
where shall I set this book?
I've got no background in anything
particular, one time will do as well
as another, I have
to look it up anyway.
So I was looking for a
particular place, and I happened
to see a really old Dr.
Who rerun on television.
I gather some of you are
familiar with Dr. Who.
Yes well, he is a time lord from
the planet galfray who travels
through space in time, having
adventures, and picks up companions
over different periods of History.
Well, in this particular he
has picked up a young Scotsman,
from 1745, this was a nice
19 or 20 year old man,
who appeared in his kilt., I said,
well that's kind of fetching,
and I found myself still thinking
about this the next day, in church,
and I said, well you know,
it doesn't really matter
where you set this book, okay
so you need to start somewhere,
why not Scotland, 18th century?
So that's where I began,
knowing nothing about Scotland,
or the 18th century, having no
plot, no outline, and no characters,
nothing but the rather
vague images conjured
up by the notion of a man in kilt.
[laughter] Which, of course, is a
very powerful and compelling image,
as all of the ladies
here could tell you.
Going back to the Germans, one of
my later books was quite lucky,
and I won the Korena
National Prize for Fiction,
and had to go to Germany to
accept it, which was very cool,
but the German Publisher had me
interviewed during that week,
by everybody, and the German media.
And toward the end of
this very tiring week,
I was talking to a very gentleman
about a literary magazine,
they said, your work is terrific,
your nerdy drive is perfect,
your characters are
so three dimensional,
and I'm thinking yes, yes, go on.
And instead, he stopped and say,
there's just this one thing I
wonder, can you explain to me,
what is the appeal
of a man in a kilt?
[laughter] Well, I was very tired,
or I might not have said it,
but I suppose it's the
idea that you could be
up against a wall with
him in a minute.
[laughter] So, you may be
wondering what this has to do
with the American Story,
but it actually has quite
a lot to do with it.
Which is to say, that in fact,
not only did I not get a PhD
in literature, the only thing
I knew about books when I began
to write this novel, was that
they should have conflict.
That was the sum total of what,
12 hours of English
Literature in college.
It seemed to be enough, anyways,
I went to the library looking
for conflict in Scotland, in the
18th century, but you don't do
that for very long without running
into Bonny Prince Charlie
and the Jacobite.
And so that became the
material for my first book,
and again for the second book.
I was only going to write this
book for practice, I wasn't going
to show it to anyone, or
tell anyone what I was doing,
but things happened.
And I had an agent before I
finished it, and I told him,
I think there's more to this story,
but I think I should stop while I
could still lift it, and he said,
okay, and so he told them that,
luckily several people
did want to buy it.
And they said, trilogies
are very popular these days,
do you think she could write three?
Being a good agent, he
said, oh I'm sure she could.
So I got a three book contract,
and proceeded with the Jacobite
revolution, the rebellion.
Well as you well know, the Highland
Scots lost big time on that one,
and as a result, many, many, many
of them came to the Americas,
most of them involuntarily,
and here they rested.
So at the time of the
American Revolution,
one colonist out of every three, was
a Scot, and we have several of them
as signers of the Declaration,
and so forth.
Now people reading my books,
at the end of the second book,
and now the third book, and
people say, what is this,
it's not Scotland, and I said,
no, didn't you notice they lost
at the end of the last book.
Andy they said, well we want to
read about Scotland, and I said,
well tough the story went across
the ocean, and now we're in America.
So, that's where the story has
developed over the next six books,
and so forth, and became
increasingly interested
in how many different people
contributed to the American story,
at this point and time,
we're working our way
through the several years
of the American Revolution,
and we're dealing with Quakers,
and [inaudible] Germans,
non [inaudible] Germans, and with
the gales from the Highlands,
the low life Scots, also with
the Africans who were there,
most of them involuntarily as well.
Interestingly enough,
the Highlanders,
and the Africans had
things in common,
both being involuntarily there, many
of them being there in servitude,
but there was quite a lot
of cultural overlap in part
to the music and songs they had.
You will find something
called [inaudible],
singing in African
American early music,
which was contributed
to American Jazz.
What's interesting
is that you will find
that very same thing
among-st Gaelic Highlanders
who have never seen Africa,
and evidently came up with it
on their own, the other
interesting thing is
that as the gales came an indentured
servitude, still they were white,
which was kind of an advantage at
the time, and therefore they were
in some cases, made overseers of the
other slaves, I count them as slaves
as well, on plantations,
and the like.
And the interesting thing was,
that many of the Black people
there learned to speak Gaelic,
because their overseers
spoke Gaelic.
And as newly people
arrived from the Highlands,
being mapped by black inhabitants on
the docks, and there response was,
my God man, what happened to
you, the sun must be terrible.
And the thing is, there is this
cross fertilization always.
From the very beginning, several
members of my family fought
in the American Revolution,
on both sides,
as well as being German
mercenaries, my fathers side
of the family had landed
in Santa Fa in 1705,
so they kind of sat that one out.
But you know, I have always
enjoyed what we call hybrid vigor,
it means that we derive our gene
pool, and our cultural fascination
from all different kinds of places.
And the languages too
have contributed to this.
I heard someone say that
English is a language
that chases other languages down
a dark alley, knocks them over,
a goes through their
pockets for loose grammar.
[laughter] And this
is pretty much true.
However, as Miss Shetterly
said earlier,
the roots of our revolution, of
our language, of our culture,
go back to England, and the elegant
language of the 18th century,
Washington and Jefferson, mad as
much of an impact as they did,
in part, because of what they said,
as well as what they meant by it,
and so we kind of beat
Germany out by a bit,
and became a nation
of English speakers.
The funny thing is that
a lot of the philosophy
of the American Revolution
arose from English club men,
and this is where they got their
socialization, they all belonged
to societies, some of
which were philosophical,
some of which studied literature,
some of which had other views
in mind, such as the Anacreondic
society who's goal was drinking.
And they had a particular song
that they sang at each one
of their meetings which ended
with, Besides I'll instruct you,
like meat and wine, [inaudible].
Which is the 18th century
equivalent of,
let's all get drunk and have sex.
Most of you will be more familiar
with it in it's later incarnation.
Oh say does that Star
Spangled Banner yet wave,
ore the land of the free,
and the home of the brave.
And the moral of that
is, the words matter.
[ Applause ]
>> Ladies and gentleman, please
welcome David McCullough.
[ Applause ]
>> David McCullough:
What a wonderful night,
and how privileged we
all are to be here.
I just look at these
fabulous words up here,
Library of Congress
National Book Festival.
Think of what is entailed in just
those words, that we have a Library
of Congress, that we have a National
Book Festival, and to take part
in it, as one of the writers, is
for me, a very high privilege.
And I am pleased to say that I've
been involved with this event
since it's beginning in 2001, and
to prove, with all the enthusiasm
that I can, of keeping it going,
and keeping it going indefinitely.
And I want to say thank you to Dr.
Hayden, and all of those who work
with you, for the marvelous
contribution you make,
you and the staff of the Library
of Congress, to our country
and to it's betterment
in so many ways.
I have been devoting my working
life to the American story
for over 50 years,
and I'm ever grateful
that I somehow hove the good fortune
of having wandered into this way
of life, this way of
contributing what I can
to the betterment of our country.
I've done this on paper,
I've done it in classrooms,
I've done it on television, and on
the stage, and in every way I can,
to convey that history isn't
about boring statistics
and quotations, and
memorizing dates.
It isn't about just
politics in the military,
history is human, it
is about people.
When in the course of human
events are declaration begins,
and the operative word
there is human.
And I've had wonderful
responses from readers,
and television viewers, students
I've lectures in colleges
and universities all
over the country.
And the compliments I
take very much to heart,
including one that happened
in the most unexpected
way just two years ago.
In Boston, where we had that
horrendous blizzard series,
nine feet of snow, in a matter
of about a month or less,
it was a blizzard every two or
three days, with brief intervals,
where we could try to get out to get
food, to get provisions to survive.
Rosy [assumed spelling] and I were
living in Bat may at the time,
and she would make a list, I would
make a list, we would both go
over it to get what we needed.
In one particular bad series
of storms, we got up a list
of everything we needed, and I
went over, when the break came,
in the weather, and the Star Market
[assumed spelling] back then was
just a mad house of people
trying to get stuff to get by,
and it was as if the Russians were
in Rhode Island, or something.
And I got everything on the
list, except the cashews.
And as you know, you can't
survive without cashews.
[laughter] So I saw a fellow
walking by with a Star Market label
on his shirt, and I said, excuse me,
could you please help
me to find the cashews?
He said, yes follow me.
So I followed him, and we
went around a few bends,
the whole peanut, and nut
department, and I got my cashews,
and about seven minutes later I was
checking out at the cash register.
And the same fellow came up
to me, and he said, excuse me,
I don't mean to bother you,
but that voice, your voice,
were you by any chance the voice
on Ken Burns Civil War series?
And I said, yes I was.
And he said, well I want to thank
you from the bottom of my heart,
because when that series
first came on the air,
I was suffering terribly
from insomnia.
[ Laughter ]
He said, I'd hear your
voice and go right out.
So I hope very much, I won't have
that effect on all of you tonight.
I found my vocation here,
in the Library of Congress.
I had wanted to be a writer, I
had gone through Vale University,
and I majored in English,
I thought maybe like to be
like Carlton Wilder, who's been part
of a faculty there, and write plays,
or certainly not plays, novels.
I had no expectation whatsoever of
writing a biography, or history.
When I got out of college,
I couldn't make
up my mind whether I wanted to be an
actor, or an architect, or a writer,
or a painter and thought, I know
what I'll do, I'll go to New York
and something will happen.
So I went to New York, and I
wound up working for Time and Life
for six years, six and a half
years, and learned a hell of a lot,
about writing, and
about getting work done,
and getting it done on time.
And then Kennedy was running for
President, and when he called
on people, his address to do
something fro your country,
I took that directly to heart,
quit my job, came down here
to Washington, and wound up working
for the U.S. Information
Agency under Edward R. Murrow.
It was a very exciting time,
not only because we were working
for Murrow, but we were
working on the new frontier.
And I was put in charge of a
magazine for the Arab world,
and I had a very limited budget,
which I had to keep-- make work.
And one of the ways I discovered
that could be done was to search
out the resources for free
material, principally pictures,
the magazine was called
[inaudible], life in America,
it was based on Life magazine,
sold on the newsstands.
And I came up to the
Library of Congress,
to try and find wonderful
material that we could use
in the magazine, it was free.
And while I was here working
one day, I passed the Department
of Photographs, I went by a table,
and on the table was this
wonderful array of photographs,
taken by a photographer that had
gotten into Johnstown, Pennsylvania,
within days after the terrible,
disastrous flood of 1889.
and I had grown up in
Pittsburgh, and I had heard
about the Johnstown
flood all my life,
but I didn't know anything about it.
All I knew was that when we were
kids, we used to put a lake of gravy
in the mashed potatoes, and
then we'd break the potatoes
with our fork, and as they
gravy came down into the peas,
we'd say, the Johnstown flood.
[laughter] And I looked at
these photographs, and I said,
what in the world happened?
I couldn't believe the devastation.
Now keep in mind, that was
the worst man made disaster,
and nature made disaster that had
ever hit the country, until then.
Over 2,500 people died,
as many as died
in the tower in New York, at 9/11.
And I got interested in it, and
I took a book out of the library,
this library, and it wasn't very
good, the author didn't seem
to understand the geography
of Western Pennsylvania,
I at least knew that.
So I took another book out, and
it was a pot boiler at the time,
it was very inaccurate,
so I thought, no.
So, when I was in college, Thornton
Wilder was asked, how do you come
up with the id-- write the
plays and novels you've written?
And he said, I imagine a story
that I would like to see produced
on stage, or to read in a
book, and if I can't find that,
I write it so I can read it,
or write it so I can see
it performed on stage.
So I said to myself, why
don't you write, try to write,
the book about the Johnstown
flood how you would like to read.
And in effect, that's what I've
been doing with every subject
that I've undertaken
since I began this work.
I had never done historic research,
I had never taken anything more
of history than what was required
when I was an undergraduate,
I have no graduate degrees,
and I've never thought
of myself as a Historian.
I'm called a Historian,
and I'm always complimented
by that, but I'm a Writer.
I'm a writer, writing what
really happened, as best I can.
And because of a lot of writing
that I had done in college,
in the courses I took, and writing
that I had done at that time
in life, I realized, you have
to understand the people.
Who was involved?
What were they like?
What were they thinking?
How were they raised?
Where did they come from?
What were there problems,
internally, or externally?
And what were the adversities
they faced?
History is about people.
And because I was in Washington,
during the Kennedy years,
Kennedy as many if you
may remember, or know,
was asked about what he was
reading, and he was reading,
Barbara Tuchmans, The
Guns of August.
So I went out right away and got
Barbara Tuchmans, Guns of August,
I thought, whoa, this is the kind
of history book I'd
like to read more of.
So I began reading people like Bruce
Caplan, and others, and I realized
that writers can write history.
And Barbara Tuchman, in one of her
essays bout writing history, said,
there's no secret to writing
history, or teaching history,
tell stories, the American
Story, which has hardly,
been even half told so far.
For one thing, too much attention
has been focused on politics
in the military, yes
politics in the military are
of the utmost importance, but
they no means are the human story.
That involves poetry, music, art,
it involves science and medicine,
and finance, and it involves luck,
we never talk about what part
luck has played in history,
and it involves individual human
beings who made a difference.
And what began to interest me
particularly, once I had gotten
into writing, as soon as
I started doing research
for the Johnstown flood,
much of which I did here.
I've done research for every single
one of my books here in the Library
of Congress to a large degree or to
a small, but to an important degree.
My book on the Wright Brothers,
was drawn almost entirely
from the extraordinary, amazing
collection of letters and diaries,
kept by the Wright Brothers,
and their mother and father,
and sister, all right here.
And, OH, could they write!
Because their father raised
them to express themselves
in the English language
as best possible.
And he meant to express themselves
on paper, and on their feet.
They never had even
completed high school,
and yet you read those letters
here, and you think, oh my goodness,
the vocabulary, the use of
the command of the language,
and you realize, we've got a
lot of catching up to the kind
of high school and kind of bringing
up those young men experienced.
They lived in a house, they had no
running water, no indoor plumbing,
no central heat, no telephone,
but it was a house full of books,
because their father
believed you had to read.
You have to read above your level,
so there were no children's books,
they were all real books, and
they read all their lives.
I'm not, in any way
demeaning children's books.
[laughter] They stick with you side
mazy lazy bird, hatching her eggs
on tiles and on boards, with
kinks in my leg from sitting here,
sitting here, day after day,
it's work how I hate it,
I hate it, I'd much rather play.
[laughter] [applause]
When I first went,
in grade school we were told we
could visit the school library,
and this was in kindergarten,
and we went in,
and oh boy, were we thrilled.
And the Librarian, Miss
Powell [assumed spelling],
we all sat down at little
tables, the librarian said,
now did you all bring
your library shoes?
Meaning you couldn't be quiet, and
I thought, my mother didn't tell me
that you had to have library
shoes, and I felt so awful,
I felt so insecure
about my library shoes.
I can't come into any of these
libraries now without wondering
if I have my library shoes on.
But the first book I got up and went
over to the shelf to pick out was,
Horton Hatches the Egg,
the one I just quoted.
It sticks with you, it's
important, it's part of growing up,
it's part of discovering.
I often think that the book
that influenced me more
than anything was, The Little Engine
That Could, which has two lesson,
you persevere, but
also, you work together,
it's not just trying
to do something alone.
I-- I've often wondered
about why I d o what I do,
and whether I have some
weird ways of going about it,
and I've been reluctant to talk
about it openly, until recently,
and I thought, what
the hell, admit it.
I've never undertaken a
subject I knew anything about.
If I knew all about it, I
wouldn't want to work on the book.
To me, the writing, the
research, the thinking that goes
into the work, is an adventure.
It's working on a detective case,
it's stepping foot on a continent
where I've never set
foot in my life,
and I love that part
of the adventure.
I also have felt very strongly
that I wanted to give some people
that don't get sufficient
credit, credit for the first time,
bring them back, bring them on
stage, downstage, center stage,
with the lighting on
them, and bring some
of these seemingly peripheral
people up to the front,
in center stage too,
like Abigail Adams,
or Emily Robling [assumed spelling],
the wife of the great engineer,
of the great Brooklyn Bridge,
and to point out to all of us,
we can't forget these people.
John Adams, always upstage with by
two tall Virginians on either side,
but when you think of what
John Adams did in his life,
he was the only founding
father, President,
who never owned a slave,
out of principal.
He would not own a slave, nor would
Abigail allow him to own a slave.
And the first president after John
Adams who never owned a slave,
was their son, John Quincy Adams.
Now, that's not a minor attribute.
The oldest Constitution we have
in our country is not our National
Constitution, it's the Constitution
of Massachusetts, and he wrote it.
And in that Constitution there's a
clause about education that applies
as much today, as it ever did then,
and hopefully will always apply.
I felt very strongly, that the
Wright Brothers, for example,
we would learn in high school
that the first airplanes,
motor powered plane to be flown
was flown by the Wright Brothers,
but Kenny Hawkins was 19'3
and he changed the world.
But what about them?
How did they grow up?
What were they like?
What did they believe?
Well, one thing they believed is
that they had purpose in life.
Don't just go on thinking it's
all about material acquisitions,
or getting a lot of property, or
becoming famous, or something.
No! Have purpose, and
modesty, you remember modesty?
[ Applause ]
The Wright Brothers never bragged
a word about what they achieved.
The Wright Brothers never
said anything derogatory
about their rivals, never, because
that was the way they were raised.
And to be loyal, and to be
honest, to tell the truth,
and it's the way many of us, most of
us, I'd like to think, were raised.
And we still like to believe that.
And we also believe that our story,
as a country, is a
story of progress.
It doesn't always come easily,
it doesn't always come instantly,
it isn't always apparent right
away, but it is progress.
When I was working on my book about
Johnstown, I spent a lot of time
in Johnstown, and I
heard about the engineer
who helped bring the Bessemer System
to the Steel Mills, in Johnstown,
very early, one of the
earliest mills in the country
to develop the Bessemer Process.
And this fellow was always
working to develop new machinery,
new equipment, new devices,
and his famous line was--
after they'd been working for
months and months on a new piece
of machinery, he'd say,
Alright boys, let's start her
and see why she doesn't work.
That's what we're about, it's
call the Empirical Method.
You do-- you try something,
and if it doesn't work you
study why it doesn't work,
and then you fix it, and then
maybe eventually it will work.
It's been true all along.
And we are constantly making
progress which we don't recognize
as progress because we're in the
thick of it, we're in the midst
of it, as everybody always was.
When you think for example,
what's happened in our country,
in our lifetime, in medicine,
it's utterly phenomenal.
I think that future historians
may very well, while looking back
on our time, say, well that's
what real history was then,
that was history being made.
And it comes from ideas,
it comes from education,
it comes from imagination,
and genius, yes.
It does happen, because some people
really have that touch of genius,
and they should be part of History.
Those doctors who's names we don't
figure at all, we should know
who they were, and what
they did, just as is true
about our painters and our writers.
I thank my lucky stars that
I quit my job in New York,
and came to this city when I did.
It not only changed my
outlook, it changed my life,
but it's given me ambitions
to expand the experience
of being alive, through
the experience of history,
the experience of our story in a way
that probably would never
have happened, had I not taken
that step, taken that venture.
And every time I come into
this library, I thank goodness
that we live in a society, in
a country that out the library
on a acropolis, right
here with our Capital,
because that's the way it should be,
that's how we should feel about it.
And I know we all have favorite
libraries in our hometowns,
or where we grew up, but
this is one of the miracles
of the American Story, this
great Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov